il
là
heureusement que
ça marche
césar il mind
je m'appelle fred jana je suis moniteur
vtt mais je fais je pratique aussi ma
passion en dehors je viens de me faire
justement circuit de la mégavalanche
2200 mètres de dénivelé à fond les
ballons avec une bande de potes
moi vraiment ce que j'aime dans ce
parcours c'est qu'il ya beaucoup de
dénivelé il est vraiment tous les types
de terrain on commence par s'en prendre
plein les bras avec la roche volcanique
donc là ça secoue dans l'essence faut
vraiment rester bien concentré pour pas
100 m
et moi
ensuite on arrive le long de la crête où
là c'est un petit peu vallonné avec des
racines dans les sous bois qu'on a un
peu malade et fois que la lumière à bien
tous distingués mais il faut vraiment
être très concentré
et puis ensuite on descend dans des
petits single c'est à dire des chemins
plus étroit pu serrer un peu plus raide
là quand c'est mouillé a vraiment des
bonnes sensations de glisse voire même
des fois on a l'impression qu'on
contrôle plus rien et on serre les
fesses jusqu'en bas
c'est vraiment un beau parcours il ya
vraiment de tout et moi j'adore parce
que c'est vraiment une heure une heure
et demie intense avec plein de
sensations
m
après ça dépend vraiment de la
météo quoi quand c'est sec il ya
beaucoup plus d'adhérence donc ça permet
voilà y aller un peu plus sans réfléchir
et quand c'est mouillé et bien gras ya
les fameuses plaques de terre miroir
plus les racines
qui font que ça devient beaucoup plus
technique au niveau du pilotage est
beaucoup plus précis
par contre seul truc je conseille de
partir à plusieurs si jamais il ya
quelqu'un qui se malhoun importe quoi et
ensuite d'avoir du bon matériel d'être
autonome alors quoi réparer
parce que sinon vous risquez d'avoir des
gros soucis et d'arriver en bas avec ce
genre de c'est tout ce qui va vous
restez de votre vélo donc pour éviter ça
soyez prudents et partech du mont athos
aléas plus sur les pistes
moi